brothers and sisters who would have
fought an ex-soldier a British Army
soldier would have gone to Mecca and
perform umrah on top of that we had the
honor to teach him how to praise
Productions the video is going to show
you now Snippets of him in celebrities
and inshallah we're going to have an
actual interview with him of how he came
to Islam brothers and sisters he was a
new Muslim he ended up going to umrah
with the umrah company we happened to
see him there and meet him there and
teach him how to pray step by step in
front of the camera please support this
campaign at Salah plus mom and sisters
our Salah plus program helps new Muslims
learn how to pray Salah and don't forget
to subscribe to our new channel to upon
the films where we have skits and show
movies telling you everything you need
to know about Salah may Allah bless you
guys inshallah and biljas enjoy the
video the best view in the world
[Music]
guys I'm in front of the cabin what I'm
about to say is not made up praying once
Allah right here is the equivalent to a
hundred thousand just the hundred pounds
can teach up to 10 people how to pray
Salah we aren't saying we bring people
to omra but we teach brothers and
sisters like Khalid how to pray Salah
and praise all their Salah for four days
praise the janaza praise the jummah
praise you praise all their five salons
the donor gets the reward so do not miss
on this reward click the button or the
link and donate
foreign